we won in the revolution we want in
everything America
[Music]
Maltesers it's not a dog
kind of tastes like a more chocolatey
kick that to me if whoppers have more
chocolate around it that is that how the
chocolates like unusually smooth you
could sneak this into movies like
popcorn
yeah like if it was the only thing in
the house I would be tired still either
why would they call it dairy milk
chocolate pie Gary look sounds like a
yogurt blade brand or like if I was
gonna buy like ricotta cheese this
reminds me of the really long time
wrapping I was kind of expecting
something to be in the middle cuz they
look like pockets
this is solid like you build something
with things you know there's like Double
Stuf Oreos there's like a double stuffed
her shoes I would prefer her she's
baller here's your teeth
isn't there a candy already titled your
keys dogs like you it's very dense
it's like that chocolate not Nestle
Crunch both without the crunch a weak
Ghirardelli nothing special pretty
generic Lake new peel and reveal
covergirl like new peel and reveal like
something like a face mask this looks
very interesting
it's like bark and looks like trees Oh
[Music]
as a weird texture it confuses me it
definitely lives up to the name it's a
very flaky kind of taste like the powder
you make with hot chocolate there's like
a buttery taste to it it tastes very
good I'm in crust toffee Chris
looks like Lisa's wiper saw what's
obvious oh all right
oh I like this how so much happening say
like a combination of a KitKat and a
Twix crispy chewy mmm this is good
it's kind of like a crunch bar on the
bottom Wow Rose in the middle is
something crunchy
it's toffee that's what top is Wow I'm
gonna change the wrapper I just seem too
easy
I'm almost borderlining on emotionally
unstable and under to be in America
anymore cos we're really just starting
out a new relationship here and I'm
feeling like it's really positive
[Music]